hello niece and nephew it's Uncle Roger
and these are my favorite snacks
[Music]
for you this one shrimp cracker Uncle
Roger favorite
crunchy good texture fish is very good
flavor so many white people fear fish
flavor you ever microwave fish in office
piss off all the Western people
but in Malaysia we don't care we like
how fish smell
but this this is some good stuff
ah this is Milo classic Malaysian drink
this is our hot chocolate and Uncle
Roger love how every Milo can they have
someone doing spot on there but this not
healthy drink is full of sugar full of
fat if you drink this you're not gonna
do spot you're just gonna get fat I uh
nice and if you go to Street Food Store
in Malaysia when they make this for you
they mix this drink by doing this sort
of pulling motion
and then the drink mix and got nice
froth on it Uncle Roger can't do it and
not actually street food Hawker but you
get the picture
ah lucky charm this one Uncle Roger
guilty pleasure I know this just for
children but
Uncle Roger love marshmallow but I hate
camping this is the only way I get to
have marshmallow who want to go camping
now a day who have time
need to go by tent you need to set up
campfire hi uh nobody have time we have
Netflix now
foreign
milk now
that one good thing about America your
breakfast cereal are so sweet
it tastes like dessert Uncle Roger like
don't be boring
and eat granola hiya who the hell like
granola it's just boring nut and and
raisin who want that
we want marshmallow
ah and not the classic old school Asian
snack half flake this one Uncle Roger
loved growing up because it's the only
snack I can afford when I was a child
and the most beautiful thing about this
neck is nobody know what it made of the
English name is Hall flick but what the
hell is a [ __ ] nobody know is that the
philosophy of food in Asia you don't
know what it is if it could you just eat
you eat first ask question later can I
borrow a pair of scissors
Uncle Roger come here to film they don't
even open snack for me I could do
everything myself I'm sure when Tom
Holland too hot one you don't ask him to
make his own wing
but Uncle Roger he just said this
celebrity nobody give a [ __ ]
cut open the snack himself
see in Malaysia growing up you can get
this for 20 Malaysian scent so that like
seven Cent US dollar
really nice
look at this
so tiny so cute
delicious little piece citrusy little
bit sweet
um
ah Taurus black truffle chips
Uncle Roger have soft spot for Posh food
like this I know I know truffle is the
most ripped off food ever you ever go to
restaurant you just add truffle to
anything they charge 15 more High yeah
[Applause]
I know it waste of money but
tastes so good
everybody like truffle
it's like white people umami
ah and not the classic Malaysian snack
this is Mommy monster noodle snack the
how to eat this this is noodles next so
like imagine instant noodle but you
don't need to cook it you just eat the
noodle out the packet
and then you see inside the full it
looks just look like it just looked like
instant noodle
one thing you can do you can crush it if
you want
and then they give you a packet of
flavoring for you this is actually just
pure MSG Uncle Roger favorite thing
they always sell you the seasoning
packets separately because when parents
buy this for the children they always
don't let us eat the seasoning packet
my mom never let me eat the seasoning
packet you just have to Raw talk this
mommy monster hi uh who want that it
tastes okay
so you sprinkle the MSG
inside the packet
the whole packet go in
to close this and you shake
and now you enjoy
hmm
people don't eat MSG people don't eat
meat now so many vegetarian
and do you complain why you have
depression that why
pay all you need
[Music]
all you need my name is Uncle Roger and
those are my favorite snack check me out
on YouTube under my channel Mr Knight
and follow my podcast also it's called
hiya podcast everything on YouTube bye
bye
[Music]